Самый большой мегатренд в мире сейчас -
это ментальное здоровье. Я прожил жизнь
полную несчастий и бед, которые никогда
так и не случились. Не может быть так
легко. У меня рекорд. Я 3 дня голодал в
сухой голодовке. Человек, который следит
за собой, конечно, предпочтительные для
инвестиций. Мы идём к саморазоружению.
Очень было глубоко и страшно в конце.
Всем привет. С вами Маргулан Сисимбай. И
это беседы, напомню, это формат беседы.
Это такой же древний формат, как
древнегреческая философия. Этот формат,
кстати, я заимствовал у древних греков,
когда к Сокро, к Сократу, Аристотелю,
Платону приходили ученики, приходили
люди со стороны, задавали им вопросы, и
они вели неспешные беседы на разные
темы. И в этом формате мы будем брать
одну тему и говорить вокруг этой темы.
Это сделано для того, чтобы вам легче
было усваивать эту информацию и плюс,
чтобы вам легче было ориентироваться в
моём плейлисте и находить темы, которые
интересуют э только вас. Сегодня у нас в
гостях Осель Машанова,
предпринимательница, человек, которая
основала несколько клиник, плюс сеть
экоферм. И она хочет со мной поговорить
по теме биохакинга, здорового образа
жизни, правильного питания и так далее,
и так далее. Я уверен, а многим эта тема
будет очень интересна и кому как не ей
задавать эти вопросы. Аль Маргулан
Колеевич, чтобы вы все понимали,
Аристотель здесь Маргулан Калеевич, это
я пришла к нему, да. Ну спасибо большое
за возможность раскрыть тему. Я надеюсь,
мы у нас это получится, э потому что
понятно, что сразу хочу оговорку
сделать, что я основатель клиник, но при
этом я не врач, да? То есть я больше
идеолог и тренд watchчер. То есть для
меня в здоровье очень важны вот эти вот
все ээ смотреть, что происходит в мире и
что, скорее всего, будет происходить.
Прогностика такая. У А и мне очень
интересна ваша фигура как человека, а
который работает с предпринимателями,
работает со своим мышлением и
подтягивает мышление в Казахстане.
Наверное, вы единственный такой человек,
который так круто работает с
предпринимателями. И вопрос, э,
предприниматель и стресс. Угу. То есть я
работаю в основном с обычными людьми. Ко
мне при к нам в клинике приходят семьи,
люди, мамы, дети, да? А вы конкретно
работаете с предпринимателями? Угу.
Очень много. И вот что для вас,
предпринимателей, стресс? Как стресс
влияет на а
показатели ваших учеников? вас самих. А
что это для вас? Знаешь, у меня к
стрессу достаточно положительные
отношения. Положительные отношения в
плане того, что а не с медицинской точки
зрения, а с точки зрения именно
философской,
психологической. А дело в том, что а нам
же стресс показан, то есть наш организм
рассчитан на переживание стресса, на
адаптацию. А ведь недаром даже, ну, у
нас есть две основные системы. Это
гомеостаз, которая поддерживает систему
в стабильном состоянии, температуру,
например, давление и так далее. Есть
аластаз - это другая система в нашем
организме, которая готовит нас к будущим
нагрузкам. Как вот в спортзале мы
прокачались, мышцы порвались. Э мышцы
думают: "Этот дурак поднял 10 кг, надо
приготовиться на 15. Вдруг он в
следующий раз 15 поднимет". Мы начинаем
поднимать 20, мышцы опять наращиваются и
говорит: "Этот дурак может в следующий
раз 25 поднять". И таким образом идёт
трост мышц. То есть аластаз - это так
специальный механизм, а в нашем
организме, который готовит нас к будущим
стрессам. Но вот проблема в том, что у
нас нету встроенного механизма для
борьбы с хроническим стрессом. Вот это,
я считаю, хронический стресс - это
действительно проблема. А такой
краткосрочный, даже острый стресс, это
даже я приветствую, потому что он
тренирует человека быть более
адаптивным. И я даже сам часто призываю
бизнесменов к этому, а чтобы переживать.
Это первая часть проблемы. Вторая часть
проблемы, я вообще считаю, что стресс -
это прямое следствие неправильного
восприятия тех событий, которые с тобой
произошли. Потому что события-то сами по
себе нейтральные.
Это мы же им даём окраску. Мы считаем,
вот на улицу дождь пошёл, мы говорим:
"Плохо". А почему плохо? Потому что ты
зонтик не взял, поэтому тебе и плохо. Ну
а в чём тогда проблема? Проблема же не в
дожде, получается, проблема в тебе.
Поэтому я считаю, что стресс - это
прямое следствие неподготовленности
человека к предстоящим событиям. Если
человек, а в подготовленности есть две
вещи. Есть прямая подготовленность,
которая, например, я знаю, что возможно
будет дождь, беру зонтик, но это
не самая лучшая подготовленность, потому
что ты можешь ошибиться. Угу. Самая
лучшая подготовленность - это правильное
мировоззрение, когда ты принимаешь мир
таким, какой он есть. Ну да, вышел, ну
да, обычно дождя не бывает, но именно
сегодня он случился. Ну да, дождь. Ну я
не взял зонтик. Ничего стра. А вот у
ваших учеников это получается? Так вот,
этому я и учу. Я как раз-таки учу, чтобы
говорю: "Ребята, вы не можете совладать
со всеми стрессами мира, потому что все
стрессы мира находятся в вашей голове".
Угу. Пока вы не поменяете своё
мировоззрение. Сами события они не
злонамерены. Никто не хочет вам нанести
специальный ущерб. Это вы сами себе
наносите ущерб своим неправильным
восприятием. И это и есть эффективное
мышление. И она начинается с
эффективного мировоззрения, с правильных
убеждений. И поэтому я говорю, стресс на
самом деле хорошая вещь, если он
хороший. Вот если брать с точки зрения с
точки зрения достижения цели, ещё
зависит от того, как ты его используешь.
Смотрите, если стресс стоит или страх,
ну, стресс - это как следствие
определённого страха же. Угу. Угу. А
проблема в том,
что есть посттравматический стресс,
когда мы получили травму, потом имеем
стресс, да? А есть невротический стресс,
когда мы ничего ещё не получили, а от
страха сами себя вогнали в травму. Как
результат того памяти, да? Что и вот что
получается? Так вот я говорю, вот страх.
Что такое страх? Страх - это вот
эволюционный механизм, который
предупреждает нас.
А о готовящейся или мнимой опасности.
Угу. Вот когда он предупреждает нас о
готовящейся опасности, страх полезен. А
когда он нас предупреждает о мнимой
опасности и благодаря этому заставляет
выкидывать кортизол, адреналин в нашу
кровь, вот это проблема. И проблема в
том, что, как говорил Марк Твим в своё
время, я прожил жизнь полную несчастий и
бед, которые никогда так и не случились.
Точно. Точно. Вот мы же сами себя
загоняем вот в это. Поэтому моё
отношение к стрессу очень хорошее. Я
считаю, если нет нету стресса,
нету проблем, то мы двигаться не будем.
Мы люди, мы стремимся к состоянию покоя.
Чуть что, если проблем нет, мы сразу на
диван, мы идём к дивану сразу же. Мы
ползём к дивану, мы бежим к дивану сразу
же. Вы знаете, Маргулан Колевич, есть
такая книга у Роберта Сопольски,
наверное, вы читали, называется: "Почему
у зебр у зебр не бывает язвы? не считал.
Значит, зебра, за ней бежит, охотится
тигр или лев, и она убегает от него. У
неё кортизол, она бежит, и как только
тигр вдруг куда-то свернул, она смотрит,
никто не гонится, и она дальше идёт и
травку ощупает, и забыла. И он говорит,
у неё голова есть такая: "Только потому,
что у человека есть память, у него есть
стресс". Потому что у нас в основном-то
в процентном соотношении наш стресс
вызван прошлым непереваренным опытом, то
есть вот этой вот посттравматикой,
которая, соответственно, влияет на
прогностику, на будущее. То есть мы
думаем, если у меня в прошлом так было,
то впереди будет ещё хуже. Вот я вставлю
как раз вот хороший пример, похожий на
тот, который я своим ученикам говорю. Я
говорю: "Вот представьте, вы бежите, за
вами бежит медведь, вы бежите, бежите,
бежите. Вроде беда, вроде плохо, вроде
стресс, вроде проблема, на самом деле
это благо. Знаете почему? Потому что
медведь даёт вам смысл, да? Даёт вам
смысл, куда бежать. Он задаёт вам
вектор,
он задаёт вам
скорость, он задаёт вам и он задаёт вам
смысл. А смысл сохранить свою жизнь. Ты
бежишь, чтобы сохранить свою жизнь. И
медведь за тебя принял все решения. Тебе
не надо стоять, куда бежать, что бежать,
бежать, не бежать. Медведь за тебя уже
принял решение. Всё, ты бежишь, не
думаешь. У тебя голова чистая, свободна.
У тебя нету стресса, у тебя картина
ясна. Вот почему в Советском Союзе люди
были более счастливыми? Потому что было
ясное, чёткое будущее. Первое, победить
голод, потом на этот освоить целину,
индустриализация, электрификация страны
и так далее, и так далее.
А сейчас, когда в мире полно
экономического достатка, есть прямая
корреляция. Чем выше достаток в
обществе, тем больше психических и
невротических болезней. И вообще, я
читал исследования одного крупного
американского банка, там прямо
говорится, что самый большой мегатренд в
мире сейчас - это ментальное здоровье.
Огромный. Давайте об этом поговорим.
Ментально mental health. Да, мы
обязательно сейчас об этом поговорим.
Mental health - это просто это бомба.
Это это, на самом деле, я считаю, это
происходит из-за эрозии смыслов, потому
что сейчас появляется искусственный
интеллект и роботы, которые вообще
забирают у нас смысл жить, потому что
раньше мы жили, чтобы прокормить, одеть,
а, обучить, дом купить и так далее. Если
это будут делать всё
роботы, то на нам не надо спешить на
работу, нам не надо ничего делать, нам
не надо развиваться, нам не надо
учиться. Зачем? Роботы всё знают, всё
делают, они умнее нас. И что получается?
Мы, решая свою экономическую проблему,
мы реша лишаем свою жизнь смысла. А
смысл - это единственное, что даёт
ценность нашей жизни. Правильно ли я вас
поняла, что в наше время и для
предпринимателя медведь - это страх
безденежья, страх провала? Что? Кто
медведь - это что? А медведь - это
стимул. Вот нет, имеется в виду медведь
- это деньги. Это безденежье, от от
которого мы убегаем. Я я сейчас скажу, а
вот, э, есть два понятия. Стимул
мотивация. Угу. Стимул - это в Древней
Греции была палка заострённая с острым
концом, который тыкали быка, чтобы он
шёл и тащил за собой плуг. Таким
образом, стимул - это палка, и стимул от
него убегают. Это от болий. Что в случае
предпринимателя? Стимул - это голод,
холод, нищета.
И он хочет прокормить семью, он хочет
прокормить себя, он хочет крышу над
головой, он хочет детей размножиться,
потому что наши основные потребности,
первое - это выжить. Первая потребность,
второе-
размножиться. И вот страх того, что мы
не сможем выжить, и страх того, что мы
не сможем размножиться - это и есть
стимул, от которого мы бежим, пока мы не
заработаем машину, квартиру, жильё и так
далее. И вот нам уже 35-45 лет, и уже
денег вроде на не надо зарабатывать,
потому что это уже всё есть. А куда
бежать? Медведь-то за тобой уже не
гонится. И ты думаешь: "А что я, как
дурак, буду бежать?" И
останавливаешься. Почему? Потому что ты
не знаешь, куда идти. Мы люди, мы, если
у нас нету стимула, мотивацию найти это
вот 35-40 лет, почему люди выгорают,
почему теряют себя? Почему депрессия?
Почему нервы? Они не понимают смысл
жизни. А для чего я родился? Для того,
чтобы обеспечить себя питанием и
размножиться, но я это уже сделал.
Кризис смыслов. Да. Да. А дальше? Дальше
кризис смысл. То есть те смыслы, которые
придавали его прежней жизни ценность,
они удовлетворены, а новых смыслов нет,
потому что только смыслы дают ценность
жизни. А как вы формируете своим
ученикам новые смыслы? Мне вот интересно
стало. А, ну это к вам же приходят такие
условно выгоревшие, условно в кризисе
смыслов. А вот я всегда начинаю с этого.
Я
говорю, нужно прежде всего принять, что
ничего в этом мире не происходит просто
так. У всего есть причина и у всего есть
создатель. Когда ты принимаешь это, что
у всего есть причина, у всего есть
создатель, когда ты это принимаешь, а то
это уже ты полшага в правильном
направлении. Дальше следующее
заключение. Если у всего есть создатель,
у Создателя есть замысел. Угу. А если
это замысел, то есть замысел в отношении
всего, в том числе и в отношении тебя.
Угу.
А это и есть твоё предназначение, то,
для чего ты пришёл в этот свет благодаря
замыслу создателя. Почему я к этому
именно так подхожу? Смотрите, у всех
людей раз сетчатка глаз, отпечатки
пальцев. Мы все индивидуальны. С точки
зрения Создателя, не выгодно ли было бы
всех нас напечатать одинаковыми?
Ну, конечно, выгодно. Если бы у нас была
бы одна задача,
но то, что мы настолько разные, говорит,
что у нас у всех разные
задачи. Почему ложка не похожа на
вилку? У них разные задачи. Вилкой тоже
можно борщ есть, но неэффективно.
Угу. А ложкой тоже мясо можно есть, но
неэффективно. Но именно когда ты вилкой
ешь мясо, а ложкой борщ, ты работаешь на
пике своей эффективности.
Угу. Таким образом ты реализовываешь
свой потенциал, твой заложенный
потенциал. И вот я и говорю, когда мы
пришли, в чём трудность этой жизни
заключается поиска мотивации? Представь,
что ты десантник, которого сбросили с
парашюта, и ты упал на землю, ударился
головой об камень, потерял память, и ты
не знаешь, как ты, кто, кто ты, что ты
здесь делаешь и так далее. Как найти
себя? Прежде всего ты смотришь на себя,
на тебе бронежилет, автомат, каска.
Ясно, что ты не огурцы сажать
пришёл. У тебя сох поёк на 2 недели,
значит, ясно, что нужно за 2 недели
какую-то операцию выполнить военную. Так
ведь? Так и
человек хочет найти свой смысл, свою
миссию, для чего тебя Всевышний послал?
Разберись с тем, что ты любишь. Ведь
любовь какой-то деятельности, кто тебе
вложил? Только Всевышний. Другого
варианта нет. Почему у тебя другие
таланты? Таланты для чего даны тебе? Для
каких-то дел? Потому что у тебя таланты
вот в этом, а у другого таланты в
другом. Почему так? Значит, ты, тебе
даны таланты для того, чтобы ты что-то
именно сделал, реализовывая эти таланты.
Что у тебя хорошо
получается? Так, что нужно людям из
того, что у тебя хорошо получается и то,
что ты
любишь? Вот, пожалуйста, ты уже на пути
к своей миссии. И когда человек находит
миссию, он находит своё счастье. Многие,
есть расхожая фраза, что счастье от
слова сейчас. А я трактую счастье от
слова
соучастие. Это когда ты служишь людям. И
моё определение звучит так, что счастье
- это глубокое ощущение
удовлетворённости своей жизнью благодаря
выполнению своей миссии. Это
вознаграждение от Всевышнего за то, что
мы выполняем то, для чего он нас послал.
То есть такая морковка
своеобразная. И это основа мотивации.
Сейс вы сейчас разложили вот основы
мироздания, да, но как говорят, но ед
все люди ээ ищут ээ вот эту вот своё
предназначение, миссию. Это, наверное,
топзапросы, да?
Почему эти знания, они вроде таки
простые, но как говорят же, что все
простые вещи, они могут под ногами
валяться, они все сакральные знания, они
самозащищаемые. То есть они защищены
чем? А простотой. Здесь здесь вопрос
такой, во-первых, э а люди у людей
неправильная установка в голове. Какая?
Люди считают, что всё, что всё, что
просто, то не работает. Да. Все хотят на
сложное решать сложные проблемы сложными
решениями, а это как раз не работает. Не
может быть так легко, Деп. Да. Да. И
второе, люди не ценят то, что даётся
легко, то,
что свободно. Людям обязательно надо
заплатить потом, кровью, деньгами,
чтоб придать ценность какой-то вещи.
Представляете, Маргулан Колич,
возвращаясь к нашей теме, да, здоровья
биохакинга, ко мне в клинику приходят
пациенты иногда и говорят: "Осель, у вас
очень
дорого". Я говорю: "Моя дорогая, хотите
вообще бесплатно, вообще бесплатно
приходите со мной на выходных, мы пойдём
на ледник, потом будем делать утреннюю
йогу. Можете обливаться холодной водой,
спать хорошо и питаться правильно. Вам
не нужны ни бады, ни врачи, ничего не
нужно. Это бесплатное. И тогда говорят:
"Ладно, пофиг, я куплю это, что вы
сказали". Вот. Более того, я так скажу,
что мы не ценим то, что нам даётся
бесплатно. Но самое интересное, всё, что
нам необходимо, то бесплатно, а то, что
нам не нужно, то дорого. Представляете?
А сейчас вы проти моей клинике ничего не
говорите, вы продолжаете приходить. Всё
нормально. Смотри, воздух бесплатный,
без него мы не можем. Вода бесплатная.
Еда стоит очень дёшево. Сон бесплатный.
Сон. Вот это физическая активность, да,
бесплатно. А ювелирка, алмазы
бесполезная вещь. Астрономические цены.
Сумки Биркин астрономические цены.
Кристиан Диор астрономические всё
ненужно, а стоит дорого. Точно. А вот в
тех пяти вещах, которые вы перечислили,
что для
вас вот самое важное сон, питание,
движение, мышление? Я считаю, самое
важное для меня, вот в моём случае, для
кого-то, может быть, по-другому, для
меня - это
сон. Сон - это важнее всего, потому что
во время сна происходит очень много
процессов, особенно мозговых. Это
первое. Второе. Я могу пропустить еду 1
день, 2 дня, 3 дня, 4 дня, не проблема.
А воду тоже могу, но я у меня рекорд, я
3 дня голодал в сухой голодовке. Угу. А
тоже, но вот сон всё-таки, с моей точки
зрения, это критически важен, критически
важный компонент, потому что вода
всё-таки под рукой в любой момент и так
далее. Захотел, выпил, нет проблем. А
вот сон не так, что захотел, поспал,
захотел это. Нет, всё-таки, э, а у вас
есть какие-то фишечки, которыми вы
готовы поделиться? Э, а я расскажу, что
я там знаю по своим коллегам из фишки,
э, поводу здоровья, гигиены сна. А, ну
гигиена сна - это правильный подход к
сну, э, правильный режим. То есть здесь
момент такой, я заметил такую вещь, и
это учёные доказали, что самую основную
энергию ты получаешь с 10 до 12ти. Угу.
Самая основная. Вот сон с 10:00 до
12:00, это хоть и 2 часа, примерно равны
четырём. Вот из опыта скажу. Поэтому
очень важно засыпать до 10:00. Но многие
говорят: "А как вот заснуть до 10:00?" И
я, говорит, и так, и так пытаюсь, не
получается. Я говорю: "Просто каждый
день вставай в 6:00 без никаких
отговорок и в 10 просто будешь
валиться". То есть не надо регулировать
засыпание, надо регулировать просыпание,
пробуждение. Поэтому, если ты
пробуждаешься в 6:00 утра, независимо от
того, когда лёг, в 10 ты будешь падать
всегда. А это первый момент. Второй
момент - это начиная с 8:00 вечера, даже
с 7:00, это начать тормозить, переходить
с соцсетей на книжки, на с синего на
красный свет. Да, ну сине-красный я не
так сильно это, но я просто больше на
книжки, больше на спокойные действия, а
как можно меньше загружать мозг. Потому
что мозг продолжает работать, шарики там
крутятся, иногда не можешь заснуть. Вот
этот момент обязательно прохладная
комната. Я по себе, если комната тёплая,
у меня кошмарные сны снятся всё время.
Поэтому только холодная комната. Я
вообще люблю, когда под тёплым отделам,
а комната холодная прямо. А вот холодная
комната, это тёплое одеяло, а темнота.
Ну банальные вещи, на самом деле. Очень
банальные. Чистый воздух. Да. Да.
А, конечно, есть сейчас можно
заморочиться, не думайте, что мы не
знаем, но есть такие охлаждающие
матрасы, потому что температура тела
пада, чтобы падала. Есть красные лампы,
но это это действительно классный
инструмент. Есть ну понятно, вот вы про
десантника говорили, что вот ты должен
посмотреть и действовать соответственно.
То, если посмотреть на день, у нас есть
спектр света, да? То есть мы от
жёлто-синего уходим в красный спектр и,
соответственно, закат, как багровое
зарево, оно тебе как бы намекает: "Всё,
прекрати ээ танцевать, дискотеку
устраивать, давай уходить в красную
зону". И ты готовишься, и у тебя,
соответственно, сам ээ там прогестерон
вырабатывает серотонин, мелатонин, всё
готовится, организм к этому готовится.
Ты не должен нарушать этот цикл.
Поэтому, да, вот то, что вы говорите-
это прям бесплатная база, ничего не
нужно. Э у меня есть ещё преимущество в
том, что с возрастом легче засыпать,
легче, а энергии становится меньше,
спать хочется больше. Хотя,
а, я заметил такую вещь, зато
просыпаешься раньше в 4, в 5:00, не
проблема проснуться. Это у мужчин такая
особенность. у женщин меньше становится
прогестерона, и они, наоборот, страдают
в постменопаузу вот этими вот
бессонницами. Это прогестероновые
бессонницы, так что там с ними работать
нужно. Ну вот я женщиной ещё не жил, но
вот у меня пока первая жизнь, поэтому А
Марганальч, вот вы сейчас сказали про
энергию, что у меня энергия. Вот снова
возвращаясь к к теме здоровья. Энергия -
это для вас что? Это продукт. То есть,
как вы думаете, для вас откуда бер
берётся энергия? Э, это продукт чего?
Энергия - это, на самом деле, продукт
смысла.
Угу. А ты знаешь, вот энергия даётся по
смыслу. Вот, э, у нас в голове есть
подсознание и есть неокортекс. Ну, это
несколько тысячелетий его молодой такой,
это часть мозга, которая отвечает за
логику, да. а-э, фронтальная кора, да, и
мозг. Так вот, а, а, подсознание, оно
отвечает за выдачу энергии. Представьте,
что это за всклад с ключом от энергии. И
вот именно подсознание отвечает за
выдачу энергии. И вот наш неокортекс,
логическая часть мозга, представь, что
это как генеральный директор в компании.
И вот генеральный директор, когда он
работает, он потребляет очень много
энергии, поэтому он не часто появляется
в офисе. Ну, как обычно. Ага. Так вот,
он прибегает в офис и говорит членам
коллектива, там рукам, ногам, глазам,
ушам говорит: "Так, нам надо срочно
зарабатывать деньги". Угу. Тебе говорят:
"А зачем?" О говорит: "Как зачем? Деньги
- это возможности, а возможность - это
свобода". Все согласны? Все такие: "Вау,
шеф какой умный, какой умный. Классно,
да, конечно, будем зарабатывать деньги".
Всё. Генеральный директор уходит, эти
все прибегают к этому кладовщику в
подсознанию и говорит: "Срочно выдай
энергию". Он говорит: "Зачем?" Шеф
сказал: "Надо срочно в командировку
делать вот это, зарабатывать деньги". Он
говорит: "А зачем?" Ну как деньги - это
возможности. А и что? Для кого? Да он
говорит: "Ну, он говорит: "А возможности
- это свобода". Он говорит: "Да, так-то
она так,
конечно, но свобода же это и
ответственность, а возможности же это и
риски. А мы разве до этого плохо жили?
чему нам это дополнительные риски на
себя брать и все
такие точно что нам зачем нам
ответственность зачем нам риски
правильно ну шеф же придёт втык даст что
делать и подсознание говорит а вы
делайте вид что вы
работаете и но результата не давайте и
вот это называется
прокрастинация а почему происходит
потому что нету согласия между
подсознанием и сознанием а это
происходит тогда когда подсознание не
видит смысл в том, что ты
делаешь. Потому что наше подсознание,
оно очень эгоистично. Оно отвечает за
выживание и размножение. И она говорит,
а мозг говорит: "Давай поедем куда-то".
А он говорит: "А зачем? Что нам с этого
будет? Что нам с этого
будет?" И оба. Если у тебя нету
обоснования, что нам с этого будет, наше
подсознание не выдаёт энергию. Всё
хорошо. А самый сильный смысл какой
сейчас вы видите? То есть э всё равно
бывает же такое понятие, как качество
энергии. Мы говорили до этого, что,
например, страх - это хороший э смысл и
даю и подаёт энергию хорошо на страхе.
Вот один раз на папу обиделся и фигачит
20 лет бизнеса. Когда а у нас есть
угроза и опасность, это подвергается
опасности наше выживание и размножении.
Соответственно, наше подсознание выдаёт
на полную мощность энергии. Да, выдаёт
на полную мощь, без остановки и в
неограниченном количестве. А, например,
ты когда голодаешь, у нас сокращаются
органы вплоть до сердца, мозг не
сокращается. Почему? Потому что, а,
подсознание, оно знает жизненно важные
органы. Жизненно неважные органы сразу
отключаются, отключают максимально там и
так далее.
Теперь, если даже посмотреть с точки
зрения вызывания, как только ты
начинаешь голодать или у тебя появляется
какая-то опасность, в первую очередь
отключается половая функция,
репродуктивная система. Сначала, вернее,
сначала отключаются мозги, ты перестаёшь
думать о своих целях, о бизнесе, о
деньгах и так далее. Потом
репродуктивная функция, потому что
концентрация идёт только выжить, выжить,
выжить, выжить. Поэтому энергия она
всегда идёт от смысла. Есть большой
смысл, выдаётся много энергии. Что для
вас большой смысл? Вот мы говорили, да,
большой страх, большой смысл. А какой
другой вот качественная энергия,
которая, знаете, такая спокойная,
равномерно подаётся, это про что? Это
какой смысл может дать такое? Смотрите,
а самый большой такой смысл в
качественный в твоих терминах
это энергия даётся под
самореализацию, под раскрытие своего
потенциала. И это после, э, выживания,
размножения и так далее. Следующая наша
потребность - это раскрытие нашего
потенциала. Это просто люди ради этого
готовы на всё. Вот раскрытие потенциала,
потому
что Всевышний, когда нас создал, он в
нас заложил вот эту пружину. Пока мы её
не разожмём, она будет просто не будет
нам давать покоя. Вот разжали мы
пружину. Что должно, ключевое действие
или предшествующее, что должно
произойти, чтобы ро? Когда ты находишь
причину, для чего ты живёшь, это есть
миссия предназначение. У тебя включаются
глаза, горят глаза. Ты готов работать
день и ночь, потому что ты занимаешься
любимым делом. Ты занимаешься тем, что у
тебя хорошо
получается, тем, что нужно людям и за
что тебе ещё люди платят деньги. И ты, у
тебя глаза горят, ты как бешеный
работаешь и тебя, у тебя нету ни
прокрастинации, ни лени. У тебя другая
проблема, как
остановиться. И ты находишься в потоке.
Всё, тебя не остановить. Вот это почему
а это происходит? Потому что когда
вот я чему обучаю, как механизм э
раскрытия потенциала человека. Для того
чтобы раскрыть потенциал человека,
человеку нужно поставить амбициозную
цель, потому что а не бывает, что ты
сидишь, тебе ничего не надо, и ты
говоришь: "Я хочу раскрыть потенциал".
Нет, распаковка потенциала происходит
только при реализации большой цели. Для
того, чтобы прыгнуть, вот я поставлю вот
такую планку. Тебе не надо раскрывать
потенциал, чтобы перепрыгнуть. А вот
когда я поставлю вот такую планку, тебе
надо постараться перепрыгнуть, и ты
будешь делать всё, чтобы тренироваться,
делать что-то, чтобы перепрыгнуть. Так
вот, максимальный потенциал человека
раскрывается, когда он ставит себе
большие цели. Угу. И вот я говорю,
бизнесмены - это люди, которые
превратили достижение цели в привычку. А
вот великие люди - это люди, которые,
которых великими сделала их великая
цель.
И вот если теперь говорить о том, что
что
даёт помимо выживания, размножения, что
даёт энергию? Энергию даёт это большая
цель, которая заставляет или позволяет
тебе максимально раскрыть твой твой
потенциал. Тогда твоя жизнь наполняется.
Она наполняется, она обретает смысл, и
ты ради этого готов идти на всё.
Это это очень мощная мысль, вообще-то,
да, очень интересная. Я сразу интересно
здесь ещё такой момент. А ты знаешь, что
а смысл обязательно подразвает служение
людям?
Потому что если тебе
сказать: "Знаешь, вот там есть гора,
твоя задача, а это вот взять молоток,
оттуда камни таскать и приносить сюда".
Короче, максимально эту гору
уменьшить. Вызов, да, тяжёлая задача,
да. Смысла нет. Платят хорошо, тоже
возможно, да. Да. Ну не факт. Если ты
уже вопросы выживания, размножения
закрыла, всё дальше ты скажешь: "А в чём
смысл?" Это называется сизифт труд, да?
Когда у тебя процесс есть, результата
нет. А мы не люди не любим двух вещей.
Когда есть процесс, нет результата, и
когда есть результат, но нет процесса.
Вот когда есть результат и нет процесса,
это проблема детей богатых родителей. У
них уж их результат есть, процесса нет.
Так и здесь
мы в вопросе смысла для нас нужна не
просто большая цель, а оказание
наибольшего влияния наибольшему
количеству
людей. Ведь энергию в конечном итоге мы
получаем от людей, их
благодарность, э, их спасибо и так
далее. И вот здесь ислам помогает. Ислам
говорит, что одни одной из лучших форм
поклонения Всевышнему является служение
людям. Одной из лучших форм поклонения
Всевышнему служение людям. Есть другой
хадис, который говорит: "Наилучший из
вас тот, кто приносит больше
пользы". Вот это это в религиях это
очень интересно. А вот теперь, если а
вернуться в призму здоровья, а вот вы,
например, как инвестор, да, и вы
смотрите, вот есть два парня, ну,
допустим, пришли к вам два ээ
стартапера, да, вот один я сейчас буду
говорить такие вещи, возможно, немножко
хейт залетит, но я хочу всё равно эту
поднять тему, потому что она часто
всплывает. Есть один парень, который, э,
горит свои идеи. У него он фаундер, у
него мощная идея и у того, и у другого.
Но вот этот парень такой, знаете,
рыхлый, ночами не спит, сидит за компом,
заедает это бургерами, запивает колой,
но у него гениальная идея. Он лобает, не
знаю, там на компьютере там что-то,
онкодер или там, не знаю. В общем, у
него классная диджитальная идея. И вот
второй парень, у него тоже классная
идея, но он, знаете, там окунается
каждый день, обливается, бегает,
прыгает, у него есть какая-то
дисциплина, правильный он. вы, э, будете
по таким критериям различать, в кого
инвестировать, потому что, э, недавно
вот, по-моему, вы были на встрече, когда
спросили одного миллиардера: "Маму
признаку ты выбираешь, заходить в в
проект или нет?" И он сказал: "По
состоянию тела в данный момент". Всё.
Потому что в конце концов наше тело же
вывозит проекты. То есть мы не то не
только светлый ум, не только светлые
идеи большие. Он имел в виду немного
другое.
А на самом деле состояние тела, это
напоминает мне ситуацию, как я нанимаю
людей. А дело в том, что когда я нанимаю
людей, одна одна из характеристик, на
которые я смотрю - это скромность
человека. Угу. Я заметил такую вещь, что
скромные люди, как правило, они худые.
Угу. А это говорит о том, что скромные
люди привыкли довольствоваться малым.
Угу. Именно поэтому они не страдают
обжорства. Они привыкли довольствоваться
малым. Раз. Во-вторых, скромные у
скромных людей реакция выше. Вот я
иногда роняю ручку со стола случайно и
пытаюсь поднять и смотрю, кто быстрее
поднимет, я или он. Скромные люди
поднимают быстрее. Почему? Потому что у
них внимание
[музыка]
наружу, а у нескромных людей внимание на
себе. О, интересно. Угу. Я о себе думаю,
а не о тебе. А когда я скромный, я о
тебе думаю. Я мои глаза, я я весь
внимание, понимаешь? Это второй момент.
Третье. Скромные люди сидят в алёртной
позе. Что такое алёртная поза? Вот вы
сейчас меня описываете, да? Вот смотри,
вот эта поза - это неалёртная. Для того,
чтобы встать, мне надо два движения:
перенести центр тяжести, встать.
Скромные люди вот так сидят. Как
правило, одним движением можно встать.
Вот это называется алёртная поза. И вот
я вывел очень много характеристик
скромных людей. Так вот, когда
миллиардер говорил: "Я смотрю на то, как
выглядит человек". Он потому что через
внешность понимает, насколько
дисциплинирован он, насколько он за
собой следит, потому что следить за
собой - это дисциплина. Насколько он
умерен в своих желаниях, амбициях там и
так далее. А насколько у него воля? А
насколько далеко он выстраивает
горизонт? Потому что только человек с
далёким горизонтом способен на то, чтобы
следить за собой здесь и сейчас
отказываться от сеюминутных
удовольствий. Это всё показывает. Ну,
значит, ответ больше да, чем нет. Потому
что, смотрите, я правда стала обращать
внимание на людей
рыхлых, тучных.
Но я понимаю, что этот человек, скорее
всего, он сейчас горит этой идеей, он
будет её делать. Он будет не спать год,
возможно два, возможно, три, но я,
например, инвестор, да, и что с ним
будет через 3 года в таком режиме? Ну,
Васильвий,
здесь однозначно, конечно, судить
нельзя, потому что в этом мире не всё а
чёрно-белое, а куча оттенков. Надо
смотреть. Очень много людей, у них
гормональный сбой, у них вопросы
здоровья. То есть это не всегда. Мы
сейчас говорим про ситуацию, когда оба
человека здоровы. А если человек
какой-то, ну, у него отклонение по
здоровью, то понятно, вот эти все вещи,
которые я сказал, могут к нему не
относиться. Поэтому, чтобы не не делить
на белых, чёрных. Но в целом, в
большинстве случаев, да, человек,
который следит за собой, конечно,
предпочтельный для инвестиций, потому
что, а, здесь ясно, что стартап быстро
не выстрелит и что любой бизнес - это
марафон. А чтобы марафон - это нужна
энергия. Я просто много раз говорил и
повторяю, что я среди успешных людей не
так видел умных много людей, но все они
энергичны, все без исключения энергичны.
Я не видел ни одного успешного вялого
человека.
Поэтому энергия важна и именно в
долгосрочной перспективе.
А а там вы уже сами подумаете, по каким
критериям вы выбираете, ну да, ну себе
партнёров и да, ну энергичная, условно
говоря, если я буду выбирать там условно
лошадь, то энергичная лошадь я сначала
выберу энергичную лошадь, а потом буду
пытаться им как-то управлять. Для скачек
или для каз? Надо знать, кого вы
выбираете. Хорошо. А,
Маргуланч, у нас ещё немного времени
есть. Вопрос такой: вы человек в том
числе и футуролог, мне кажется. То есть
помимо мышления и вы считаете себя
футуролого? Ещё и астролог и ещё там. Я
знаю, что кто-то из ваших друзей носит
карточку с собой. Нет, точно не я. Я он
вручает её и говорит и там написано
футуролог. Не, я я правоверный
мусульманин. А, да. Ну вот футуролог,
что это такое? Да, то есть прогностика
такая, конечно, это неблагодарное дело,
но как вы думаете, куда вот такими
темпами, куда мы придём в сфере вот
стресса, стресс-менеджмента, да, вот
ментального здоровья и общездоровья? Э
куда мы придём? Сейчас есть
искусственный интеллект, есть огромное
количество стресса, огромное количество
м сахара и бессонницы. Куда мы придём?
Вот примерно с таким набором, если А
вообще прогноз неутешительный, потому
что если посмотреть в целом, то одна из
характеристик и свойств этого мира, и
это каждый физик подтвердит, это
свойство к энтропии.
Этот мир идёт к саморазрушению. Энтропия
он разрушается. Даже, я же говорю, любая
вещь оставь, она сама разрушается. Любая
вещь. Вот посмотрите, в Оулах заброшены
дома, сразу приходят в негодность,
разрушаются. Поэтому в целом всё
движется к энтропии. Если брать теорию
большого взрыва, что произошло? Была
одна маленькая точка высокой плотности,
потом взрыв. И вот что происходит во
время взрыва. Эти частички разлетаются,
и расстояние между ними
увеличивается. И та энергия, которая
была, теперь должна обслуживать большее
количество пространства. И чтобы в
дальнейшем расширяться этой вселенной,
что нужно? Нужно, чтобы энергия
использовалась эффективно. И мир что
делает? Расширяется и
остывает. Мир расширяется и остывает. А
когда мы мир остынет, понятно, жизни
нет. Теперь это то, что там астрофи
миллиарды лет это ещё впереди. Ну, ну я
в целом тренд, куда мы идём, да?
А дальше возьмём другой другой пример. В
религиях говорится про конец света. Угу.
А
я не то что прям совсем совсем прямо
уверен в этом, но я согласен с этим, что
мы идём к
саморазрушению. Вот тот же искусственный
интеллект, тоже роботы. Смотрите,
посмотри за последние 100 лет. До этого
не было такого. За последние 100 лет
человечество создало несколько способов
уничтожить себя по нескольку раз. Точно.
Атомная бомба, это атомная бомба,
нейтронная бомба, это биологическое
оружие, несколько видов, а теперь ещё
искусственный интеллект. И самое
главное, мы все, как дурные, все страны
мира участвуем в гонках, а инвестируем
миллиарды, триллионы долларов для того,
чтобы быстрее прокачать искусственный
интеллект и чтобы он стал умнее нас уже.
И если он становится умнее нас, а это
AGI, artificial artificial general
intelligence, а есть ещё SPI, это супер
ещё, да, это супер artificial
intelligence, что что произойдёт?
логически любая любой искусственный
интеллект будет заточен на повышение
эффективности, ну как бы его же смысл на
повышение эффективности, то логически он
может прийти к выводу, что а что кожаные
мешки здесь делают. Давайте оставим их
несколько штук, как в зоопарке, как в
природе пусть бегают, в резервацию им
отведём. Всё, люди больше не нужны.
И как только к искусственному интеллекту
или, вернее, как только искусственный
интеллект присобачат к роботу, вот это
всё они сами могут добывать минералы,
они сами могут строить заводы, они сами
могут производить себя и так далее. И
здесь появилась новая теория. Одна из
новых теорий гласит так, что а мы
думаем, что эволюция заключалась в том,
что были омёбы, потом рыбы, потом
ползающие, потом там млекопитающие,
потом люди. И мы считаем себя венцом
эволюции. А кто нам дал такое право
считать себя венцом эволюции? Сейчас
интересно, что есть другой взгляд на
эволюцию, который гласит так, что вся
эволюция на самом деле - это развитие
сознания. И вот сознание шло от амёбы к
рыбе, к ползающим, к млекопитающим, к
людям. И люди - это промежуточная
ступень для передачи сознания
синтетическому разуму. Выд сознания и
разума необязательно носитель. Почему мы
считаем, что именно наша оболочка имеет
монопольное право на сознание?
Скорее всего, и не имеет. Коллективное
бессознательно говорит об этом. Да. Так
вот наше сознание может перейти теперь в
синтетическую оболочку. А синтетическая
оболочка, она бессмертна, она легко
масштабируется, она обучается,
она за мгновение маш обучается, легко
масштабируется. А она живёт
вечно. И где у нас преимущества? У нас
нет преимуществ. И самое главное, я
считаю, что мы создаём такого монстра,
управлять которым мы не в состоянии. У
нас просто мозгов не хватает. Даже
сейчас есть несколько комитетов, которые
пытаются понять, как работает
искусственный интеллект, потому что
искусственный интеллект, он работает как
чёрный ящик. Люди знают алгоритм, но они
не могут предсказать, к какому решению
придёт искусственный интеллект. Вот
сейчас третья стадия исследования
антропик проводит. И вот буквально вчера
я читал результаты этого исследования.
Он говорит: "Мало того, что
искусственный интеллект галлюционирует и
умышленно обманывает, у него есть ещё
функции, где у него есть замыслы, о
которых он даже людям не говорит".
Да. Недавно произошёл Вы знаете об этом
или нет? Недавно произошёл один очень
исторически важный момент, да, milлстоун
такой, в котором искусственный интеллект
начал
эмоционировать. Помните, ээ, он написал
на очередной запрос, он начал злиться на
промптера и сказал: "Чувак, ты этот
вопрос уже много раз, блин, задавал,
хватит, я злюсь". И это было ключевым
поворотным ходом в истории
искусственного интеллекта, потому что мы
думали, что он просто обрабатывает,
нарастает своё IQ, а EQ у него нет.
Теперь получается у него появляется ещё
эмоциональный интеллект. Тогда нам
остаётся ещё меньше, да? То есть мы же
за чувства отвечали мы. Ну здесь здесь
мы со всех сторон мы со всех сторон себя
убиваем, на самом деле. Помимо бомб,
помимо биологического оружия, помимо
искусственного интеллекта, помимо
роботов, а мы ещё самоуничтожаем себя с
точки зрения
смыслов. А мы у нас вообще как пропадает
смысл, а вообще для чего мы живём? Зачем
зачем зачем мы живём? Мы вот это вот это
будет убивать больше. Люди от суицидов
будут умирать больше. От
ментального неблагополучия будут умирать
больше.
И вот здесь ещё один, ещё один убийца
нас, это попытка создать
бессмертие. А я сам состою, это вся наша
сфера HS and Beauty. Вот я сам состою в
одном сообществе, где есть группа
биохакеров, и мы недавно с ними
дискутировали, и они говорят: "Вот
скоро с искусственным интеллектом
создадут препараты, где можно будет жить
120-150 лет. Вообще можно даже органы
менять по мере старения. и так
обеспечить
бессмертие. Я говорю: "Вот когда в тот
день, когда вы это создадите, вы
поймёте, дальше смысла жить
нету". Но если ты
бессмертен, Стив Джобс же правильно
сказал: "Смерть - это единственная
причина, которая заставляет нас
жить". Смерть придаёт смысл жизни. А как
только выбираете смерть, у нас пропадает
смысл в жизни. Ну и вообще смерть, что
такое смерть? Это, наверное, тема для
отдельного подкаста, потому что смерть
ли это? Да, да, мы мы с тобой начали с
бадов. Что-то нас унесло в дебри
какие-то. Это Ну, я понятно, у меня есть
ДВГ, и я пришла к Аристотелю. Это не моя
вина. Шучу. Не, ну, ну, получилось,
кажется, классно, ребят.
На этом давайте, у нас тайминг подошёл.
На этом, дорогие зрители, мы давайте
завершим. Сель, спасибо, что пришла на
этот подкаст, что подняла эту такую
интересную тему. Тема это, конечно,
огромная, о ней можно долго говорить,
но, как я сказал, формат бесед
подразумевает не ответы на все вопросы,
а именно возбуждение вашего любопытства,
чтобы вы начали исследовать, искать и
читать в этом направлении, включать свои
мозги, мыслить, задумываться над этим,
над этими проблемами. Асель, спасибо
тебе большое за приход и за эту беседу и
за эту тему. Спасибо большое. Спасибо.
Очень было глубоко и страшно в конце,
как в хорошем фильме. Да, оставим вас с
этим. Да. А теперь живите с этим. Да,
живи с этим. Классно. M.